1936 pierre brasseur et odette joyeux
ont un fils qu'il prénomme claude en
1956 c'est à dire 20 ans plus tard le
petit brasseur le fils de brasseurs fait
son premier film et en 1986 cinquante
ans plus tard c'est la gitane de
philippe de broca alors de césar en
dakar le petit brasseur est devenu
claude brasseur et puis maintenant
brasseur tout court
alors voici brasseur
[Applaudissements]
bonjour brasseur bon gentil mais alors
il ya des brasseurs à la fiche depuis
1820 exact je m'excuse d'ailleurs mais
c'est comme ça alors quid de la
prochaine génération
est-ce qu alexandre brasseur va devenir
brasseur lui aussi alors il l'est déjà
élan à la tension il veut faire il veut
faire du cinéma et du théâtre
ce que je souhaite avant tout c'est
qu'il ait envie d'être acteurs parce que
très souvent les mots comme ça on a
aperçu un petit peu superficielle du
métier et ont envie d'être veut d'être
vidée de stars crois qu'avant tout il
faut avoir envie d'être acteurs et puis
après c'est le hasard la chance qui fait
le reste et votre père vous voulez vous
soyez acteur ou non on père m'a toujours
laissé libre ma mère souhaitait que je
sois architecte à d'accord j'ai fait je
fais quelques jets de bombes et offre au
projet j'ai laissé tomber archi et mais
je comprends très bien leur situation
enfin de tous les deux m'ont laissé
libre mais en même temps il avait envie
de me laisser libre mais c'est vrai que
quand on est dans une situation comme
était la leur et comme est la mienne
vis-à-vis de mon fils on peut on peut
avoir des doutes est ce que c'est pas
parce que ça lui paraître une solution
de facilité
être acteur mais faut être bon ah oui ça
d'abord tout simplement déjà avoir déjà
en avoir envie parce que il ya quand
même pas mal d'acteurs et puis c'est
important c'est de travailler je sais
que si je n'étais pas vedette
je serais très heureux de pouvoir
exercer mon métier
n'importe où dans des théâtres de la
périphérie aussi alors que sa soeur vous
sortez un vice que je montre à la caméra
s'appelle chasseurs de rêves est un peu
un peu particulier sur un peu
particulier alors on va en parler est ce
que vous croyez pas qu'après ce qui
s'est passé sur le sur le dakar c'est un
peu bizarre de sortir un disque qu'on
appelle finalement la chanson du dakar
j'ai pas la chanson du dakar et puis je
tiens à préciser puisque vous me donnez
l'occasion que le disque a été
enregistré
bien avant et pour des raisons
particulières quand je dis bien avancé
non seulement bien avant l'accident mais
bien avant le rallye lui même puisque
j'ai fait ça dans le courant du mois de
décembre
un producteur est venue un jour me
me demander si je voulais participer un
enregistrement dont les ventes seraient
au bénéfice d'un groupe de médecins qui
travaillent sous le nom de l'ambassade
et ce groupe de médecins se met au
service des différentes manifestations
manifestations sportives comme le dakar
de cette année comme le rallye des
pharaons comme d'autres rallyes d'autres
petites manifestations sportives
municipales se met également au service
de manifester de manifestations
artistiques comme des concerts de rock
et la vente et les droits de ce disque
seront au bénéfice de cette société mais
je suis content de vous m'aviez posé la
question parce que c'est pas du tout
quelque chose c'est pas dans un esprit
mercantile et non pas du tout la preuve
et c'est pas du tout pour courir après
un événement très bien l'organe vos
projets dont on n'entend plus parler
mais c'est vrai que vous faites beaucoup
d'autres choses
c'est cette pièce de théâtre écrite par
schaeffer qui a écrit amadeus et où vous
incarnerez y est bizarre et ce serait la
fin de l'empiré inca mis en scène par
polanski enfants rêvent tous de vous
voir là dedans mais c'est pour quand le
brasseur
bon on n'en parle pas parce que je
n'aime pas parler des choses quand elles
ne sont pas d'actualité
je crois pouvoir dire qu'on va commencer
à répéter cette pièce à la fin de la fin
de l'année et que là on entendra parler
puisque je pense qu'on va commencer à
jouer en tout environ du mois d'octobre
à peu près d'accord mais voilà une
information merci bonsoir sur avis de
t'avoir parce qu'en général dans les
émissions de télé on a toujours des
stars quand les films à vendre et toi tu
es là et a pas de film avant c'était
parce que les bains sur notre habitude
les bains sont dans mes habitudes et
puis en plus ce sont les plus
intéressants de moi aussi de faire des
émissions on n'a rien à vendre parce que
quand on a pu sauver à rendre
obligatoire
de vendre ce que l'on a avant tandis que
la bombe a alors que c'est une
coloration comme ça on va prévendre
tourne encore en ce moment en ce moment
je tourne l'argent ouais que mes romans
de zola de la somaca avec crouch you et
miou-miou qui ne soit pas programmé
avant avant un an et puis puis avant
j'ai fait dans des sorties elle va
sortir en janvier j'veux pas grand chose
à vendre choc dans cinéma parce que
c'est vrai que monsieur mes jambes je
vais me d'affaires d'une année une année
4 et alors tu en es où sur ce projet de
blizzard d'après la pièce de schaffer's
dernière fois je te vient interviewer
c'était dans scoop à la une est utilisé
je ferai pas le dakar cette année parce
que je polanski va mettre en scène
bizarre de schaeffer lens est devenu
quoi cette histoire ça a été j'ai tout
simplement retardé à la place de la
pièce de schaeffer mis en scène par
romane j'ai joué dans un molière mis en
scène par plongeon c'est pas mal non
plus ce qui est pas mal non plus humaine
faire le blizzard oui je pense qu à le
faire on va le faire après je pars dans
non le feu des pro juste comme ça
jusqu'à 80 m oui des projets pas des
projets pas des projets des envies et
s'il est en vie voilà ces demoiselles
je parle des projets trop signé parce
que un petit peu profondes
je vais faire le dakar cette année non
vraiment enfin cette année qui veut dire
en janvier non non non parce que
aujourd'hui je reprends je reprends
d'andar au tnp y est
donc ça correspond je fais je fais deux
ans pendant deux ans je n'aime pas sur
le dire car moi je leur ferai encore
très honnêtement je ne sais pas non je
ne dis pas je ne prends pas un jeu digne
j'ai dit je ne sais pas je ne sais pas
parce que moi j'aime bien marché par par
pulsion alors bon je les fais j'ai fait
six fois de suite quand même pas mal
on l'a on l'a gagnée trois fois par
équipe pour gagner une cause 4,83
on a toujours eu des places d'honneur 3e
2e et 5e
bonjour je sais pas si c'est une je
pourrais compris dit que c'est une
passion mal à la seule et unique passion
que j'ai c'est mon métier laventure
d'aventuré banques souffraient
paris-dakar ressemble une aventure
m'enfin le théâtre est notre métier
c'est une belle aventure mais que ce
soit le dakar où que ce soit la vie tu
as l'air de bien mais tu éclaté quand
même parce que dans les périodes comme
en ce moment on ne voit pas mal dans les
boîtes on ne voit pas mal par la nuit
aubin why are d'ailleurs
bien roulé à fond la caisse dans la vie
dans une riche veuve est toujours
toujours et puis non mais c'est pas mal
n'est ce pas vrai je suis pas je préfère
dire à la télé donc je peux dire je veux
dire une chose à la télévision c'est que
je fais une grosse différence entre les
halles colonies gros vous important à
dans un esprit oui c'était c'était une
définition de travers et je peux
inscrire
je parie que j'ai des campagnes et
ardent des voix n'ont pas pas toujours
quand je peux
j'aime pas l'alcool comme par contre le
temps en temps andres et
je vous invite brésilien s'est bien
comporté avec le diable avant tout est
bon c'est vrai que j'aime bien les
endroits où j'aime bien venir est ici
ouais et à paris c'est quoi tes boîte
préféré à paris il y en a très peu
montré que 400 bah oui il semble un
costume un casteur ça va c'est un bon
c'est un bon choix
c'est beau circuit est ce que tu crois
que tu as la même chance que ton père au
niveau des réalisateurs et quand tu
tournes est ce que tu penses qu'il a eu
des réalisateurs des scénaristes plus
avec plus d'envergure que ceux avec qui
tu tourne toi aujourd'hui en france qu
il questionné à propos du cinéma on
n'échappe pas non plus à me plaindre
il faut voir ça pour ça continue t il à
fait aussi leurs affaires générales bag
abattoirs il a tourné avec armes et guet
millions la tournée calvaire j'ai eu la
chance de tourner de tourner court noir
est tournée qu'il faut un bon sens je
pense que le compte est bon pour le
moment oui bon c'est ce qui compte et
qui compte c'est la moyenne est ton fils
alexandre et steve en faire un acteur un
bras troisième génération mange dort
presque
d'abord ce transfert ce ne sera pas la
troisième génération ce sera la
quatrième plus avance parce que je tiens
très actif il n'y avait que il n'ya que
des clowns dans ma famille 1820 donc
c'est vraiment encore beaucoup plus loin
que ça
quant à lui je lui ferais rien faire la
seule chose que je souhaite qu'ils
fassent quelque chose qu'ils aiment et
est ce qu'il a envie d'être acteurs pour
le moment pour le moment oui
j'ai envie j'ai envie qu'ils aient envie
maintenant le brasseur
et
savon soir denis robert dont vous venez
d'entendre l'interview en santé
coulisses un garçon soit je vieillis de
kersauson et qu'on ne présente plus eve
angeli votre voisine jamie cartonne top
50 qui alain chamfort qui est l'un de
mes chanteurs l'un des mélodistes
préféré voilà c'est là claude très bien
vous n'avez pas votre montre là non pas
parce que votre père vous avez dit c'est
exact et review quand on se donne en
donne son temps donc on enlève ça montre
c'est un très bon conserver la faites
moi plaisir est revenu à mon pape
voilà obéissez à votre père donc
justement la pièce que vous commencez le
6 février au théâtre de la porte
saint-martin s'appelle conversation avec
mon père oui
donc voilà de herb gardner alors
l'adaptation est faite par jean claude
grumberg mise en scène de marcel bluwal
voilà alors l'auteur de conversation
avec mon père c'est herbe gartner qui
est l'un des trois ou quatre grands
auteurs dramatiques américain des 50
dernières années
c'est lui qui a fait des clowns par
milliers qui a été jouée par yves
montand avec eu beaucoup de succès à
l'époque je ne suis pas rapoport qui
était joué par jacques dufilho et cette
pièce conversation avec mon père et je
permets de le signaler puisque c'est
maintenant il est quand même aussi un
des grands scénaristes américains on lui
doit old rajaona et la liste de
schindler oui oui l'histoire c'est
l'histoire d'un père et deux fils l'un
d'entre eux est joué par serge
hazanavicius
vous vous êtes le patron juif d'un
bistrot new yorkais qui a débarqué de
dessin en 1936 sous le nom de isaac
goldberg et qui en fait se fait appeler
et dire hausse mais qui veut s'intégrer
dans la société américaine mais qui
reproche à son fils de perdre ses
racines quoi voilà c'est un peu certains
de ces pins des deux thèmes
de la pièce parce que je pense que dans
toutes les grandes pièces il ya toujours
plusieurs thèmes qui sont abordés encore
le thème de l'immigration
vu sous un angle très particulier où on
démontre la différence qu'il y ait entre
la première génération d'immigrés
et puis les fonds des générations
suivantes
et c'est en général la première
génération des vitesses qui est mon cas
ce qui est mon grade dans dans la pièce
tous touchants libre échange et de
non-échange d'architecturé champ de
nourriture échange de langage
c'est terrible c'est eux qui défriche tu
étais là tandis que la seconde
génération mais quand ils sont chez eux
lui il fait tout pour être américain
alors que ses enfants sont américains
dont une femme et le deuxième thème qui
a demandé qui est intéressante pour ça
que ce qui me fait plaisir que la pièce
s'intéresse les les jeunes c'est le
problème des rapports entre un père et
un fils c'est à dire que l'erreur
commise souvent par amour par les
parents ses deux de vouloir pousser
leurs enfants dans la direction qu'ils
veulent eux un sens essayez plutôt de
2,2 de trouver ce pour quoi ils sont
beaux et eon le rôle que j'interprète
est un échec complet puisque je voulais
que veux que mon fils soit 12 de l'un
devient la véritable à nike alors il
devient effectivement un véritable
américain un peu stabilisé suivre nos
travailleurs gagnant du pognon pu
finalement le m'aperçois que les mecs
qui bossent comme des dingues qui ne
dorment que quand ils prennent un taxi
qui deviennent milliardaire sur des gens
qui m'emmerde de l'autre je veux faire
aussi un vrai américain je veux en faire
un héros je l'envoie à la guerre il est
tué ouais donc deux échecs c'est génial
des récentes de l'effet ce qui est
génial
claude c'est qu'en vieillissant vous
avez vraiment de plus en plus la voix de
votre père et je vais appeler ou à
laisser un message sur mon répondeur et
j'entends à la hausse et brasseurs est
bien seul coup je me suis dit j'ai
l'impression d'être mort est au paradis
et d'entendre pierre brasseur c'est vrai
que chez les brasseurs la comédie c'est
une histoire de famille on connaît
puisque votre fils alexandre brasseur
ça marche très très bien pour lui
j'espère me dis donc ça va marcher
s'annonce bien il était dans maigret
avec bruno cremer sur france 2 hier
1 il écrit un court métrage qui raconte
la difficulté de dire je t'aime à son
père mais il dit c'est pas du tout auto
biographique entre l'interview parce
qu'il dit avec mon père ça va très bien
on s'appelle pratiquement tous les jours
exact
on va paraître votre vie
[Applaudissements]
vous êtes né en 1936 à neuilly vous êtes
le fils d'eau des jo aux yeux de pierre
brasseur vous faites partie d'une
dynastie du théâtre qui remonte à
l'époque de la restauration à 1820 10
820 alors le premier brasseur c'était le
créateur du théâtre des nouveautés
après il ya eu jules directeur du
théâtre des variétés
son frère albert comédien vedette alors
votre prénom est le vrai nom de votre
père c'est pas brasseur c'est espinasse
oui et là on va parler de votre vrai
grand père qui était un personnage assez
assez extraordinaire dire que votre
grand mère a eu donc cet enfant avec
monsieur espinasse un qui était pierre
brasseur votre père alors c'était quoi
c'était un gigolo magnifique conte un
très mauvais et était très beau et puis
il ya ma grand mère qui était comédienne
également mais celle l'énervé parce que
elle se prenait elle était une artiste
mais ça se voyait pas alors pour que
l'on sache que c'était une artiste elle
avait remplacé son sac à main par une
boîte à biot long oui pour moi comme ça
on va me prendre pour une artiste mais
là il ya un très beau jeune homme qui
l'a qui lui a fait la course dans un
autobus et qu'ils laissent sur
l'impériale de l'autobus et quand votre
père raconter l'histoire jacques brel il
l'a mis dans leurs fringues c'est
l'abstention bruxelles c'est
extraordinaire oui et il invitait alors
il doit donner des tickets d'état les
lois ne le cherche encore parce que ce
n'est ni plus ni moins qu'un figurant
hallebardiers qui était dire que en fait
il était il était l'amant de sarah
bernhardt regardais un théâtre il avait
fait croire à votre grand mère qui est
une grande vedette du théâtre voilà ce
qui fait qu'il a dû excusez moi
l'expression la sauter dans la loge et
que votre père est né pierre brasseur
est né ainsi voilà mai mais un jour
quand mon père jouer qui ne devait être
sarah bernhardt une mère n'est resté un
peu avec le concierge on a fait le tour
on est monté dans les loges et m'anime
je sors certainement d'une de ces loges
la voilà alors c'est espinasse est mort
à 24 ans d'une cirrhose du foie et votre
perte à wismes tu veux te faire comme
vous a appris le nom de jeune fille de
sa grand mère c'est à dire aux brasseurs
exact alors votre maire c'est odette
joyeux évidemment
qui a été célèbre par entrée des
artistes par douce par le mariage de
chiffon enfin des films et sendets les
monuments voilà et quand votre père la
rencontre d'être joyeux elle a 18 ans et
sur le tournage de grisou et et l'huile
est séduit par sa fraîcheur
il ose pas la toucher et sarko aime
toucher baisse de fuilla oui mais
finalement oui oui oui mais même après
le mariage il a considéré comme un
enfant et elle dit dans ses mémoires
d'ailleurs c'est un petit peu difficile
avec pierre brasseur et votre père sur
le plan ce plan charnelle elle dit nous
vivions comme de chasse aux orphelins ce
qui vous a pas empêché effectivement de
naître un an après le mariage malgré
tout que le brasseur voilà dans une
enfance génial mais vous avez côtoyé
jouvet sarthe montand signoret cocteau
kessel et lyrique était votre parent oui
bah c'est un peu comme tous les enfants
du monde c'est à dire que l'on côtoie et
on vit dans le milieu de ses parents est
souvent les les enfants on voit les
collègues de bureau bah oui
effectivement les collègues de bureau ni
l'on paierait des gens que vous venez de
citer
je suis toujours reconnaissant mon père
de saad de ne jamais écarté alors oui
c'est comme ça sert qu'en fait vous
n'avez jamais eu à rentrer dans le
métier vous êtes né dans le métier quoi
contrairement à beaucoup de gens qu'on
reçoit qui ont eu du mal à rentrer dans
le système
vous vous étiez quoi oui il ya une
statistique officielle et internationale
que 70% des enfants reste dans le même
créneau professionnels pas le même
profil mêmes peines aux professionnels
que leurs parents oui ça me paraît
normal on te fâcher les médecins
aujourd'hui chez sportif bien sûr alors
vous dites votre père m'a toujours
garder avec moi ils ont quand même mis
en pension
oui hein c'est très malheureux en
pension bridge avait semblé maintenant
avec notre ami kersauson et moi un peu
et c'est une médaille d'une péripétie
très désagréable mais pas honte de
raconter je suis d'une génération où un
adolescent pendant l'occupation qui fait
que je j'avais peur parce qu'il fera
mais bref
qui dit peur dit oh oh dis que j'ai
pissé au lit très tard et au collège de
la rue
cette année et à la première récréation
du matin on nous faisait tourner autour
de la cour de récréation sous les rires
des enfants parce que des enfants ne
sont pas toujours tendre avec le drap
accroché autour du cou va mouiller du
pipi de la nuit alors évidemment les
mollahs à l'épisode 1
et puis un jour un jour c'est vrai j'ai
les
j'ai voté et il y avait une branche par
terre j'ai attrapé la branche début j'ai
commencé à faire le clown faire le con
mais en allant faisait d'artagnan je me
suis à 27 capes et je me suis rendu
compte que les enfants riaient mais il
ne l'est plus du tout de la même façon
c'est-à-dire qu'avant ils riaient contre
nous et d'un seul coup ils se sont mis à
lire avec nous c'est déjà quelques jeux
vous êtes révolter alors la punition été
supprimés dans les mails humiliation
dans votre esprit n'a pas été effacés
non c'était pas agréable à vivre
un aux études ou fonds chez moi j'aurais
vérité un vrai manque carrément ya que
la récréation qui me plaît parce que à
la récréation de son fait et on fait
l'acteur ou les gendarmes ce que je
continue alors vous rentrez rentrez
comme photographe à paris match yannick
donne absolument extraordinaire un jour
porter en hollande avec walter 40 d'un
grand photographe et vos parfums
hollande les digues des polders avait
cédé inondant 55 voilà et la hollande
était entièrement inondées et donc vous
arrivé là bas avec walter cajon donc
pour les photos pour match et il y avait
déjà une centaine de journalistes laren
je leur ai dit il déballe passé à
pareille puis il se serait calmée mans
et puis il me dit moquer crise on
assiste en attendaient ce qui me choque
des termes d'aidé mais trouve moi un
chat 1 - ch alors bon je suis parti à
l'atelier de trouver un chat et puis à
nîmes
amy tu vois la barre il y avait un arbre
au milieu cette immense étendue d'eau il
me défoule jazz soul assure larmes alors
le futur chien circulé ne fait la photo
du rni reparti
c était la photo la plus vendue
territoire fait le tour du monde le
symbole à l'inondation dolls des jeunes
la mise en scène belle histoire mais
alors voilà vous faites le photographe
fromage c'est évidemment grâce aux
relations vous aviez de par votre
service relativement facile de faire du
people oui et un jour vous allez voir
elvire popesco la grande elvire popesco
pour match et elle vous dit pauvre con
tu ne dois pas faire ce métier de
journaliste tu dois faire acteur cder
mon père qui m'avait donné le curé
meslier kouthia reportage qui est
intéressant à faire popesco vient
d'acheter le théâtre de paris
et elle va créer une pièce de marcel
pagnol
effectivement elle m'a engagé pour jouer
trois rôles un frère de julien
charpentier
je crois que je vais tout de suite trois
répliques est ensuite passé au cinéma
vous jouez dans le pays d'où je viens de
carnets et l'équipe de tournage bat
s'installe dans une caserne et là les
officiers vous dit bah tu dois faire mon
service militaire
pourquoi tu viens pas en algérie vous
partez en algérie un peu inconsciemment
faut bien le dire totalement
et là vous découvrez une autre réalité
qui est la réalité de la guerre et vous
voyez des soldats qui font des cartons
sur ceux qui bravent le couvre-feu
ce qui m'a le plus frappé c'est que ces
tortures étaient en général exécutés par
des appelé les militaires doivent y
avait des gars qui avaient il y avait
des baroudeurs qui revenait d'indochine
qui est terrifiant et eux non c'était il
y avait un malin plaisir chez les
appeler seul vêtu d'un uniforme d'un
seul moule 1-2 super représailles et
vérifier c'est annoncé mme amal non
c'est la tienne
ah non c'est moi qui blasés ou même club
racer un jour comme ça vous trouvez en
face
maintenant est ce qu'on appelait les
fellaghas à l'époque et il va dégainer
vous dégainez avant lui voue le tuer
exact toute la vie vous regretterez de
ne pas avoir eu la culture politique
d'être un objecteur de conscience est
vrai c'est vrai parce que les
générations d'un collège mon pote 18
chez les oratoriens juin est
effectivement
la télé la radio est formellement
interdit les journaux qu'on laissait
pénètre à l'intérieur du traité journaux
sportifs et on avait effectivement que
nous qu'une aucune culture politique
en sortant du collège mont blanc en
marque capitale culturelle ont parlé
pour dieu voilà c'est ça vous n'aviez
pas celui là quand votre père quand vous
avez la croix de guerre est fou de rage
parce que évidemment ça correspondait
pas du tout à ses idées il vous en veut
à ce moment-là il m'en veut
oui ma envoyez-les un temps de 10 ans de
petit con ne va pas porter ça n'oublie
jamais que quelques secondes près une
décoration c'est une raison sur m
voulait beaucoup que vous avez fait le
paris dakar
vous avez jamais écraser personne
ça fait un max de blé
ouais six fois le dakar quand même un
oui très sportif avoue on a besoin de
s'entretenir faut pas oublier que dans
notre métier nous sommes à la fois
instrumentistes mais on est aussi
l'instrument vous connaissez brasseur
nuit puis 3 millions d'années chez
castel ouais je vous ai fait la fête
ensemble olivier tous les deux là parce
que c'est un sacré fêtard brasseur il y
toujours pas alcoolique mais ibra n'est
pas du tout la même chose donc c'est pas
la musette d'un site web ça c'est pas de
moi c'est une définition de prévert
absolument vous avez fait la fête
ensemble
il est certain qu'au détour de certaines
nuits nous ne croisons oui et est
toujours de façon drôle vous êtes bien
fait sauter la tête vous quand même oui
hein
il faut dire aussi une chose c'est
difficile d'aller au lit après le
théâtre c'est un peu comme si un mec
aller se coucher à sept heures du soir
en sortant du lion au jour de l'an à
minuit
le pire est à venir
maintenant c'est l'interview nul
on ne bouge pas pendant le tri n'égale
bien pour l'aider à olivier si vous
voyez qu'à un moment il a du mal en tant
que vieux copain de débauche vous pouvez
les voilà alors est-ce que vous
préfériez votre père ou votre mère à ses
interviews nul je vous ai prévenus je
préférais mes grands mères
ouais le mot le plus con en amour pour
vous c'est merci alors où oui oui
alors heureuse et pour vous alors oui
oui pour toi c'est quoi le mot le plus
con avant moi je te rappelle imaginez
vous croisiez un extraterrestre le matin
comme ça on acheter des cigarettes
il vous dit t'es qui toi vous lui
répondez quoi et toi
si vous étiez en vente dans un sex-shop
vous seriez quoi revendre dans un check
in et vous savez quoi comme objet un
préservatif mais je vais vous dire
pourquoi parce que c'est exactement la
même chose que les metteurs en scène les
préservatifs
ça rassure quand on en main mais quand
il y en a pas qu'est ce que c'est bon
maintenant une question nul qui m'a été
envoyé par email parce que vous pouvez
m'envoyer des questions évidemment par
gym de béthune savez vous pourquoi les
abribus n'abrite pas les bus je me veux
dire à la question si vous aviez un
fermier chez vous voulu apprendre
briller quelle phrase tu à fermer le gaz
tu as pensé à la capote ou coco arrête
là coco je dois apprendre est resté à
qui attribue riez vous le plus de
circonstances atténuantes
un vieux qui se tape des jeunes où un
jeune qui tapent sur des vieilles il le
vieux qui stoppe dit rien ouais alors
vous préféreriez passé la nuit avec anne
sinclair lors sinclair ou brett sinclair
ben je vais lire le 5e ce que je connais
pas les deux autres et ça lui soit
plaisir et vous carso moi je vois ça je
veux pas passer la nuit toute façon non
c'est moi j'ai toujours vu ces choses là
comme une livraison
maintenant c'est à dire que y'a une
heure d'arrivée une heure de départ
voulez-vous les chiens une question
michel drucker que j'ai piqué oui oui je
raconte tout ce qu'on est généralement
je vais bientôt le voir nos coeurs je
vais bientôt le voir entraîner vous la
poser
[Musique]